[Música]
[Aplausos]
ah
[Música]
eran las cinco de la mañana llovía y
hacía frío
yo tenía unos 16 años
me levanté puse la pava sobre el fuego
dejé matthei el bombillo un costado y
agarré el cepillo el betún y la gamuza y
como todos los días dejé todo preparado
para que mi padre se levantara se tomara
unos buenos mates con espuma se calzarán
los zapatos bien lustrados y se vaya a
trabajar
era un día
como cualquier otro pero ese día tomé la
primera decisión importante de mi vida
ese día decidí que debía hacer algo más
por mí y por ellos
no tenía bien claro que iba a hacer
y realmente si alguien me lo hubiese
preguntado hubiese dicho que
como deporte prefería el voley un
misionero bárbaro
hoy a los 50 años todavía me
me sorprendo a veces cuando cruzó gente
por la calle que me mira como si ésta no
sería mis manos como si ésta no
no sería mi piel como si en la persona
que les está hablando no sería yo
es el mito del éxito es el mito del
éxito que te hace ver como algo raro
como algo extraño como como que no sos
humano
y justamente de eso me gustaría hablar
con ustedes compartir algo
y contarles qué
hay tres cosas que me han acompañado
durante toda mi carrera
son tres cosas simples pero que para mí
han sido fundamentales
tener un objetivo claro
la humildad y la disciplina objetivo
claro humildad y disciplina
de ese día de lluvia
yo focaliza mi objetivo
y como les decía no tenía bien claro que
iba a hacer pero estaba decidido a
a intentar lo posible y lo imposible
para forjar un futuro diferente
en esa época hace varios años en la
época de los 80 90
el 99% de los chicos que intentaban
llegar a ser profesionales en el fútbol
fracasan
en la pensión de giles
estudiaba porque así me lo exigían
y entrenaba a todos los días
sabiendo perfectamente que sólo el 1% de
nosotros lo lograría y en la pensión
éramos 8 si quiero no me daban las
cuentas no
no me daban las cuentas
un año y medio tardó mi primer contrato
en llegar un año y medio lleno de dudas
un año y medio sin
sin saber si los eternos viajes en el
norte a rosario que en esa época le
ponían 10 horas si esos eternos viajes
para ir a dormir abajo de una tribuna de
cemento abajo de una cama que no era de
cemento pero se parecía
a entrenar a estar lejos de los amigos
de los padres de mi novia
sin saber si todo ese sacrificio me
llevaría a un logro concreto
un año y medio recién les había dicho
que la expectativa de la carrera de
futbolista era de 10 años así que yo ya
había gastado el 15% del tiempo que
tenía a disposición
había había que seguir
entonces en rosário conocí a uno de mis
más grandes mentores marcelo bielsa que
no sé si les pasa pero uno
suele escuchar a las personas que admira
que respeta de alguna manera
y yo he aprendido en mi juventud
debía escuchar uno de los momentos más
esperados por mí cuando era un niño
cuando un joven era la sobremesa de los
domingos
ahí podría escuchar las historias de mis
abuelos de mis padres de mis tíos de los
amigos de ellos
y siempre podría rescatar algo
por supuesto que había infinidad de
historias y muchas terminaban en un
final feliz
y otras no tanto
y ahí aprendí a escuchar desde desde la
humildad porque ay me di cuenta que yo
no sabía todo lo que lo que yo creía que
sabía
me di cuenta que escuchando desde la
humildad uno puede rescatar siempre más
allá de la persona que tenga enfrente de
su condición social
o de su aspecto siempre se puede
rescatar algo y siempre mantuve esa
humildad de ese aprendizaje
inclusive muchos años más adelante
cuando mi carrera ya estaba firmada si
lo puedo así se puede decir
me tocó un técnico que me sugirió que me
cortara el pelo para poder jugar en su
equipo
por supuesto qué
me pareció una broma porque yo ya hacía
67 años que juega en italia
para mí tener el pelo largo era como
caminar no sé cómo vestirme era una
marca registrada
y me sorprendió y hay uno afuera la
humildad de la que le hablaba antes la
humildad
que me ayudó a controlar el ego que en
esa época lo tenía allá arriba
había hecho un montón de goles jugaba ya
en la selección así que uno tiende a
a volar así que esa humildad me ayudó a
controlarlo y a decidir de cortarme el
pelo porque me di cuenta que mi objetivo
era hacer historia en la selección
y eso era mucho más grande que cortarse
el pelo
y más adelante también un caso en
donde me ayudó mucho
yo jugaba en la fiorentina vino a la
roma a comprarme
en la fiorentina yo era poco menos que
un rey puede hacer cualquier cosa aparte
de jugar mal podría inclusive decir
algunas barbaridades que nadie nadie me
decía nada porque ya me había ganado el
respeto
en esos seis o siete años que había
estado ahí entonces la roma lógicamente
dice night este está cómodo ahí no lo
tenemos que entusiasmar lo tenemos que
incentivar así que me prometieron todo
lo que se puedan imaginar me prometieron
desde la cinta de capitán a la camiseta
número nueve
a un montón de cosas que es inútil
nombrarlas pero me he prometido sobre
todo
pelear por el campeonato que era una
cosa que yo estaba buscando
y hay otra vez la humildad me jugó una
buena pasada
y me dijo no vale la pena entrar a ese
vestuario ese grupo de jugadores
con la cinta de capitán atropellándose
es mejor entrar como uno más dispuesto a
trabajar y aprender como todos los otros
entonces les dejé la cinta de capitán a
totti dijo totti por ahí algunos saben
de fútbol es uno muy famoso que en ese
momento no era tan famoso pero ella ya
de capitán porque era un romano y
nosotros jugábamos para garro le dejé la
camiseta número 9 monte la
y me enfoqué mi objetivo que era ganar
el campeonato y era mucho más grande que
una cinta o una
a un número
no puedo decir que estas dos decisiones
han marcado mi carrera pero sí puedo
decir que puedo afirmar que varias de
estas decisiones si lo han hecho
hace un tiempo no es mucho para dos
semanas volví de europa me fui a hacer
una prótesis a un tobillo por ahí los
más veteranos acá no veo mucho luego
muchos jóvenes pero durante mi carrera
en el tobillo fue mi punto débil
siempre sufrí con los dolores de di
tobillos
eso era un dolor
me estaba olvidando lo más viejo por ahí
saben que me dolía a veces el tobillo lo
que seguramente no saben es que todos
los días de mi carrera me dolió el
tobillo
ese dolor
ese dolor que es con mayúsculas ese
dolor que cuando vas a apoyar el pie
cuando te levantas
estás esperando a ver cuándo te va a
doler si te va a doler mucho positivado
en el poco si te va a dejar ir al baño
ese tipo de dolor
me acuerdo del dolor y me duele el vida
bueno la cuestión es qué
no me venció el dolor
seguir adelante seguir caminando
inclusive cuando estaba en river
ahí es donde había hecho la mentalidad
de esta estuve seis meses sin jugar la
verdad que me entrenaba igual o más en
mis compañeros y llegaba el domingo y
afuera y el otro domingo y afuera y así
seis meses
seis meses donde por supuesto se me pasó
por la cabeza varias veces volver a
rosario que era el club donde donde yo
había surgido donde había donde había
salido era un club que conocía un equipo
de compañeros una ciudad que me quería
me sentía protegido pero yo quería
triunfar quería triunfar y no podía
aflojar si quería triunfar debía exigir
me más debía sacar fuerzas de donde no
las tenía
y debía continuar a desafiarme y hacerlo
y hacerlo y hacerlo y fue así con esa
mentalidad que
no me venció ni el dolor ni esa
sensación de fracaso
mucho más adelante tampoco me gano
me ganaron las distracciones las
distracciones que vienen con el éxito y
con el dinero y con la fama
estaba pensando esto y me emocionaba un
poquito pero eso es lo que yo llamo
disciplina
la disciplina mental la disciplina que
nunca me permitió abandonar que siempre
me permitió mantener el ego en el lugar
que correspondía la disciplina mental
para seguir el objetivo que tenía hacia
arriba
la única cosa que me interesaba la
disciplina física
para entrenarme a pesar del dolor de
tobillo
para entrenarme como si fuese el último
entrenamiento como si mañana como si no
habría mañana
disciplina
la misma disciplina que aplicaba todos
los días para levantarme preparar el
mate ilustrar los zapatos
gracias
[Música]
[Aplausos]